congresswoman Acacia Cortez is speaking
now she's angry at the mayor of New York
says he's not showing leadership on the
illegal immigrants flowing into the city
watch
and that we are joining the city
[Applause]
thank you I'm happy to be here
[Music]
our members of our delegation as well as
other members from other states that are
here to see from themselves
what the migration Dynamic is in our
nation and what we saw Away With
Children
people that want to work people that are
fleeing violence be people that are
fleeing flee
environmental disasters we see so many
stories heartbreaking stories manifest
himself here but I think these are folks
that will take New York City to a better
place every crisis presents great
opportunity There's Hope and opportunity
so I wanted to thank
you to think but we are all Americans
and we all believe in the American dream
that's the common denominator the
American dream we believe in it now we
will fight for it with that yeah and
ultimately I think that there are three
points of consensus here that are very
important in getting a solution to this
issue the first is that there is there
is consensus here across geography and
States on increased Federal resources to
cities and municipalities dealing with
this issue the second is to allow for
work authorizations so that the folks in
here can get to work and start
supporting themselves as soon as
possible they are prevented from getting
jobs they are prevented from employment
and that is part of the strain on our
public system the faster that folks can
access the work that they're asking for
legally the better we can solve this
problem and
attention of temporary protected status
for Venezuela who are the largest
population that are arriving here
thank you
the American dream will not be bullied
into submission today we will continue
to fight for the American dream we will
not be bullied will we not put me push
into a corner we will fight for these
Common Sense Solutions
we asked for the Venezuelans and
extension they already have TPS
work permits for people that just want
to work for their families
additional funding yes for New York City
needs more funding so we can get this
done God bless you America we love you
thank you we had a fight for a
supplemental that will include funding
and language in it that will guarantee
[Music]
wow New York City Representatives along
with the congresswoman Alexandria
kazia-cortez dealing with a shout Fest
right here in New York City
they are ready for close the border and
anti-illegal immigration is their stance
and some of the words got pretty
colorful and they were drowning out the
congresswoman and other Democrats who
were there you saw her lay out a plan
and on that plan I'll keep it short she
wants to quickly push through work
authorizations for the many men
particularly adult men you see flowing
on the streets of the city
um because they are now in a situation
where the shelters
are full and they're starting to release
and before they can make their way out
of the city before they go anywhere else
you see people lining up trying to get
resources
um all right we understand that
representative Jerry Nadler is there
Democrat can we hear him let's listen
it's been doing a great deal to your
system
[Music]
that is why I support additional funding
for the sheltered services and program
in a supplemental budget to give
additional resources to New York and
other cities welcoming migrants
unfortunately House Republicans seen set
on T funding the Department of Homeland
Security and shutting down our
government I also led a letter with
immigration subcommittee ranking member
jayapal and over a hundred of our
colleagues the urge the administration
to use all these tools available to them
to provide stability to Asylum Seekers
and undocumented immigrants in our
communities the Administration has the
flexibility to provide faster access to
employment authorization documents and
to protect families and redesignated
Venezuela for temporary protective
status I was proud to join this is
bipartisan letter regarding is common
sense idea the problems that led to
Venezuela's previous designation in 2021
remained pervasive today the solutions
my colleagues and I are advocating for
Australia within the administration's
purview and will benefit the soil
immigrants make America strong nowhere
is that clearer than right here in New
York in the city it's always changing
one constant is that people from around
the world want to come here to build a
better life for themselves and we're all
the better for that thank you okay thank
you okay you want to say something about
what's happening
do you want to understand what's
happening here in New York City
New York is uh welcoming countless
migrants who set up this uh Center here
at the at the
Roosevelt Hotel to process these
migrants to make sure they're fully
vaccinated to make sure to connect them
with relatives and send them on their
way if they know where they want to go
to give them employment
you know where they're going on the tour
because there are some issues I'm sorry
[Music]
and we need more help from the federal
government without question okay and one
of the key things the federal government
can do is to declare that is to provide
temporary protective status of
Venezuelans Venezuelans from more than
half the migrants so they can get work
permits immediately okay and can you
identify yourself for Congressman Gerald
Nadler of New York right here in fact
okay excellent hey everyone I'm Emily
compagno catch me and my co-host Harris
Faulkner and Kaylee mcineny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12 pm
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights